the love between lois lane and superman
has spanned across 80 years of dc comics
so
naturally things have gotten a little
weird every now and again from messed up
marriages to role play gone wrong here
are some of the strangest things about
lois lane in superman's relationship
smallville takes the unconventional
route to romance when lois lane appears
in the show's fourth season
let's just say that meeting your
amnesiac future lover while they're
standing naked in a burning field isn't
exactly the meat cute dreams are made of
unless you're into that kind of thing
which as it turns out clark kent and
lois lane definitely are
it all goes down in the first episode of
season 4 when lois shows up to
investigate the death of her cousin
during her road trip she winds up in a
cornfield where she discovers clark in
the nude lying in a burned patch of corn
when supes gets up on his feet he
insists that he's fine to which lois
quite rightly answers
you've just been hit by lightning you
start naked and
you don't even remember your own name
you have a fairly loose definition of
fine
lois and clark's will they won't they
flirtations last for five whole seasons
on the show and even after they start
dating there's something awkward about
all of their banter and palpable sexual
tension
but it never gets quite as weird as that
day they ran into each other in that
half-scorched cornfield
having a kid and saving the world at the
same time is no easy feat
finding out that your children
multiplied while you were out saving the
world is even harder but that's exactly
what went down with the aeroverse
version of superman
this version of lois lane makes her
first appearance in the arrowverse
crossover
episode elseworlds in which lois and
clark reveal that they're expecting a
baby
cut to crisis on infinite earths a year
later where the couple have one child
together called jonathan
unfortunately the notorious villain
known as the anti-monitor is busy
destroying multiple earths in the
multiverse
when everything's said and done the gang
can only save one earth
and reality as they know it is altered
forever at the end of the story the
superhero jon jones restores the
pre-crisis memories of his allies
but things are kind of different in the
strange new version of earth
especially for those who remember how
things used to be take superman for
example
clark who began the day with one child
is kind of surprised during a phone call
with lois when she mentions their sons
plural clark i need you to get to
metropolis now it's the boyce
the boys yeah honey you're sons congrats
clark
again everyone always looks forward to
the supercharged romantic climax of a
love story when the couple finally
kisses
at first glance it seems that superman 2
provides that moment with gusto
until you realize what's actually going
on that is first introduced in action
comics number 306
superman has occasionally demonstrated
his ability to mind white people with a
kiss
the concept of messing with someone's
memory is shady even with random
bystanders but doing it to someone you
supposedly love and trust is much
worse instead of kissing lois for the
right reasons in the 1980 film
superman uses his amnesia trick as a
power move to alter lois memory when she
figures out his secret identity
given that knowing superman's secret
doesn't seem to change how lois feels
about him his actions come off that much
crueler
even worse if superman intends to remain
close with lois in both his forms she'll
likely just discover the truth all over
again
after all this is super sleuth lois lane
we're talking about here
and if she does figure it out again
chances are she'll put together the fact
that superman messed with her mind
something that won't exactly go over
well superman's gonna have a lot of
explaining to do after that little stunt
when you're as coveted a hero as
superman sometimes one of you just isn't
enough to go around
luckily within the panels of the comic
book world anything is possible
even splitting yourself in two and in
superman
162 supes does the unthinkable he
separates into a red and blue version of
himself
naturally this has consequences when it
comes to clark's love life with both
lois and lana another of superman's
major love interests marrying their own
version of the man of steel
lois settles down with the red version
of superman on a newly restored krypton
while lana wed's blue subs ultimately
chilling out on earth
it's not exactly the most conventional
arrangement but since when is superman
settled for anything less than five
shades past
extra and sure polygamy may not be
everyone's cup of tea but hey
if it works it works any fan of
smallville will have felt the pain of
watching michael rosenbaum's lex luthor
try
and fail to be the best version of
himself but what if lex really could
turn good
that's gotta be impossible right wrong
in superman's girlfriend lois lane
number 34 lex kidnaps lois
as most supervillains tend to do on any
given weekday however as lex makes his
usual threats against her the aliens on
the planet omar
set the super villain on the straight
and narrow carrying him of all evil
doing
he and lois then strike up an unlikely
friendship and the reformed villain even
asks her to marry him
lois initially declines but when lex
turns up to save her from trouble
instead of superman she begins to
rethink her decision
eventually lois falls for her old captor
and she finally accepts his proposal
of course superman being the charmer
that he is is more than happy to move on
to his second choice
poor old lana lang everyone knows
there's nothing like a good fairy tale
but you can always trust a comic
book to make things weird take action
comics number 243 for example
in which superman and lois act out their
own version of beauty and the beast
superman gets cursed by a sorceress
named cersei who slips a potion into his
drink in an attempt to extort him into
marrying her
he refuses her of course convinced that
his kryptonian makeup is impervious to
her sorcery only to find himself swiftly
turned into a super lion lois then
proves that her love for superman is
thicker than fur
kissing him during a fairly awkward date
night and because subtlety isn't really
a thing in comic books the actual beauty
and the beast plays out on stage at the
same time
sadly unlike the fairy tale couple this
kiss doesn't magically solve superman's
bestial woes
before lornley accepts his fate and
resolves himself to hanging out at the
zoo
until he realizes that cersei laced her
elixir with kryptonite
as a result he's able to figure out the
cure but still lets lois have her moment
by thinking it was her kiss that did the
trick
what a cutie when you're doing the old
will day won't they dance with an
award-winning journalist chances are
good they're going to ask questions no
matter how well you hide yourself behind
a pair of glasses
however despite both clark and superman
spending plenty of time with lois he
still tends to punish her whenever she
gets close to uncovering his secret
identity and sometimes things can get a
little out of hand
the debut issue of superman's girlfriend
lois lane starts off in a fairly cringy
note that sets a tone for the whole
series
this issue follows lois as she dons her
own disguise as a successful actress to
dupe supes into agreeing to an interview
superman the king of disguise is somehow
offended by lois's own use of deception
so to teach her a lesson the caped hero
dances clark kent disguise and pretends
to jump off of a building right in front
of the terrified reporter
of course superman assures it
traumatized lois that he saved clark
just in time
obviously supes could only have been
crueler to lois here if he had pushed
her off that ledge
and things don't get much better from
there either throughout the series
superman strives to find new and twisted
ways to torture
lois for getting too close to the truth
in superman's girlfriend lois lane
number 48
lois has the opportunity to uncover
superman's identity as the man of steel
recorded his secrets on a tape he gave
perry white
which is only to be played in the event
of his death tempted to listen
prematurely lois eventually decides to
do the right thing and superman
overhears
so he rewards lois by offering her a
chance to guess his fabricated secret
identity in three time periods of his
choosing
as a result the kryptonian transforms
her into helen of troy
florence nightingale and cinderella and
it's with that last one that superman
really crosses the line
what seems like an amusing game turns
sour when superman disguises himself as
cinderella's evil stepmother
he subsequently begins abusing her
forcing her to clean mocking her
appearance and generally treating her
like a slave
think about it superman had countless
potential characters to roleplay but he
chooses the abusive option just to throw
lois off the scent
given that the game was his idea to
begin with it's fair to say that no one
forced him to go to such extremes to
hide his identity he could have picked
any time place and character to emulate
but he went with the option to belittle
and harm
lois role play is all well and good if
everyone's having fun
but this is practically superman takes
the hold till death do us part bow a
little too literally when he marries
lois's dead body and superman's
girlfriend lois lane number 103
the tale begins in the previous issue
after lois meets a shifty man during the
exotic animal parade
after drinking the stranger's magical
elixir lois sprouts horns a tail and
hooves
needless to say clark kent isn't happy
about this but lois ends up in the
crossfire when superman confronts the
mysterious figure masquerading as the
devil
during their fight a wayward laser blast
off of superman's chest apparently
killing lois
of course superman blames himself in a
bit of despair the kryptonian finally
admits his love for lois and cries out
wedding vows over her assumedly dead
body
which let's face it probably isn't the
romantic wedding lois envisioned for
herself
luckily as it turns out lois was never
dead after all
the devious devil turns out to be an
alien who takes her to his home world in
the hopes of convincing her to marry him
she then sees the ring superman put on
her finger and demands to go home
who would have thought that clark's
post-mortem wedding vows would save the
day after all
following lois's ongoing trend of
tricking superman into marrying her the
pair
enter into a whole new realm of
weirdness during superman's girlfriend
lois lane number 42
after lois snaps a picture of superman
mid-change a car crash alters her
personality and as a result she gives
superman a choice
marry her the next day or she'll develop
the film obviously every great romance
starts out with a blackmail scheme
and things go predictably well here too
while attempting to stall the reporter
superman flies her to the fortress of
solitude but when she arrives she
spritzes herself with a dose of
rejuvenation spray and begins to rapidly
de-age
the age difference prevents the pair
from acquiring a marriage license but
that doesn't stop lois she sprays
superman with the serum and they both
continue to de-age in quick bursts
eventually they get the go-ahead to
proceed with the marriage despite
basically looking like toddlers
then by the time the wedding rolls
around both parties are literally babies
still everyone is chill with moving
ahead for some reason until it turns out
that lois and superman are unable to say
i do to each other since they can only
speak in baby babble
look it was the 60s okay
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one